and we canceled all of our episodes
we have a housekeeper and she goes my
sister tested positive
and we're like okay we're all [ __ ] up
and then
weird it was so weird that that night
i had a 100 degree fever we both
started to feel sick and weakness yeah
and i guess it was what we think it was
either
in our head or the indian food i had a
100 degree fever
i mean i had 100 degree i took my
temperature ila's still that like
ela has been doubting me this whole
thing i'm like look at the thermometer
they say 100.3
and you didn't get there but my
temperature was elevated normal
temperature is like 98.6
but you didn't make it to the point
three yeah but i felt
see this is why ela is driving me crazy
i felt feverish
he either wouldn't give me that no yeah
no you felt
favorish i agree with that but i think
i don't know what are you a doctor when
you [ __ ] 100.3 what is that
that's what google says google
i'll trust google are you crazy are you
ready
so anyway we got tested and we're not we
don't have it but
it was really scary and so now i feel
like we dodged a bullet
and we're just going to be super super
safe from now on i canceled thanksgiving
i cancelled everything because you know
what right now it's so crazy out there
150 000 new cases 65 000
hospitalizations 1500 000 tests today
you know and and guys
trust me you do not want this disease
one way or the other like dr
dean friend of the show is tweeting out
research showing that
people who get covid for reasons they
don't entirely know but it
confirms something they suspect about it
which is that it attacks
the nervous the central nervous system
is that people recovering from covet in
the first
90 days have a 25 or 25
of them end up getting treated for
mental
uh mental illness first time anxiety
depression or
or uh insomnia and i was like dude
you trust me you guys you don't you do
not want this and at this point it's so
it's just so out there we are so [ __ ]
as a country that
it's now just about protecting myself i
just got to protect myself
every there's just too many [ __ ]
there's just
too much poison like the well is too
poisoned nobody is willing to take this
seriously as a collective
and um there's just you know you just
gotta
you just gotta take care of yourself at
this point trust me you do not want this
thing
they don't even know everything about it
you know
so some people in the chat that had it
yeah yeah of course there are i mean
there's been 10 million americans or
more
now that that have had the disease so
chances are you know
that's like one and 30. every one and
thirty people is that right dan did you
do the numbers on that
uh there's yeah roughly i guess
yeah i usually assume you do it wrong
thank you it's just the same i think
there's
330 million people right 10 million or
almost 11 million now probably have
gotten it yeah
so that's a little it's like one in
every 32
i mean that 33 that that's a lot i mean
that means that with 6 000 people here
someone is saying i've got it right now
oh my god
yeah i mean good luck man
i wish you were sweating yeah just chuck
i just chug coffee that's why
great anyway i was just it was kind of
but like also it was really stressful
even just thinking
that i had it so who knows what causes
the mental anguish but
the whole thing is just it's a nightmare
i feel like my whole life was flashing
in front of me when i thought we had it
because all of a sudden it's like oh my
god we got a quarantine and then we
can't take care of theodore i don't know
what you're supposed to do that was so
scary
thinking what to do with them and
obviously you can't work and who knows
how long you're going to have it
and it's like such a scary
yeah you know i don't even care what's
the
what is the governor saying to do i'm
just gonna take it as seriously as i can
i'm not doing anything oh well the
people with br everybody with a [ __ ]
operating brain is telling you to cancel
all your plans stay inside
i mean we're on the verge of another
nationwide lock down here
because it's just 150 000 new cases
yesterday it's increasing like by
seven percent every day exponentially
meanwhile you have literal uh uh elected
officials saying
do not wear a mask you know i saw this
one q anon
lady from georgia a tweet from her today
she said
today we're going to talk about masks
with my constituents do not wear them
they're a sign of oppression
be free it's like okay
awesome cool there's a donation saying
i do love them like as if some
if someone said otherwise i don't know
you love math
well some people look better with masks
because like they're lower i do
love den you do love dan oh we weren't
debating that
oh yeah i love dan too
thanks for putting that out there it was
only two dollars so that's
you dan yeah because
[Music]
but you know what i say to people that
say i love freedom so i'm not wearing a
mask
you know it's the ultimate form of
freedom death
totally free forever
[Laughter]
total freedom without bounds yes your
spirit will be without bounds
in the afterlife are we going to get
teddy fresh masks
at some point yes you are we just felt
at first like everyone was making
them so we kind of felt like i don't we
didn't want to get involved in it but
since it seems like this isn't going
anywhere anytime soon
um we do have some in in development
right now
you know i i think it was my mistake i'm
usually the one the alarmist here i've
been sitting around
uh hitting the alarm bells on covert for
a while and i go oh well by the time we
develop this thing it's gonna be gone
nobody's gonna want masks
i was wrong in that one but you know
[ __ ] i actually we
we did something really cute for it like
you know the bear patch
that we put on everything it's going to
have a bear patch and the bear has a
mask on it oh that's awesome and it came
out so cute
that is what's up so maybe it's good we
waited because our
other idea wasn't that good
um
but to be honest i really missed doing
the show for a week i was kind of
depressed
and the news has been really depressing
me i know joe biden won but like
the amount of [ __ ] dog [ __ ] that i
see people saying
i feel like i'm not experiencing your
experience because i'm not on twitter
and i think that's a real experiment
right i gotta get off twitter
how we have two different realities
right now but i just
i'm so i find myself so compelled by it
because
like we have a president who is but it's
the algorithm you're crazy the [ __ ]
it's like the algorithm sees what you're
interested in and then they show you
well i started following
all these accounts oh great well that's
what the algorithm did
it showed you who to follow well okay
you watch social
dilemma you sound like social dilemma
no unfortunately i did this to myself i
followed all these political accounts
but like i just i can't i mean is this
not important like i know
what you should just shut up and wait
but like is it not important that you
have
like literal members of the cabinet and
senators and
people saying that the election was
illegitimate and that there was massive
fraud when there's no evidence of it
i mean it's scary it's [ __ ] up and i
don't think that i'm sure that joe biden
like there's no there's no question he
lost and if they're
if they'll need to they're just gonna
drag him out of there and i know he'll
become president but the amount of
damage they're doing it's like they're
laying the groundwork
in four eight years they'll be called
out on their
whatever nonsense and it will just fade
away
i think it's like a cult and when a cult
leader all of a sudden gets caught
and you know goes to jail or whatever it
just disappears and then the people are
like oh my god
i don't know how was i brainwashed but i
somehow ended up in that cult
i hope you're right but i don't think
that's what it is it's a cult
i think there's going to be someone who
comes around and again and uses the same
strategy as trump who's not as orange
or or uh corrupt
or or you know what i mean like he's
there's so much obvious things they hate
about trump
but there's someone who come around
slicker and they're already eroding all
of our
norms and our i think
everybody is just gonna try but there's
so many people that believe that it was
a fraud there's [ __ ] it's like you
could [ __ ]
convince them them of anything it's just
what anyway it's just
you know i gotta stop thinking about it
right is everyone watching the vow
i mean you just kind of like
people end up in a cult and they don't
even know how it happened
and then when it ends they're like oh my
god like how did i end up in this [ __ ]
yeah i don't i don't i i hope you're
right but i don't you need to get off of
twitter
and i'm serious well anyway that's just
what i've been kind of depressed i've
just been
depressed about it it's just been kind
of sad to see to
you know senators seeing
the elections of fraud and [ __ ] like
it's crazy but okay whatever
they're not killing jews yet
but this doesn't the stuff like this
always ends up bad for jews somehow
i kind of had the opposite experience i
kind of enjoyed or covered the scare
because i got to just yeah
and not go to work and really get easy
let's watch like five seasons of peaky
blinders
we're the [ __ ] peaky blinders my name
is billy kimbo
anyway guys let's get to the show uh
that's just that's just what's put on my
mind but
yeah we missed frenemies and we missed
all the all these great [ __ ] we had
planned i was very sad about that but
we'll be back next week same as always
here to slam some bradburys and get it
going you know what i'm saying
now before we start our planned episode
now that i'm done kvetching as they say
if you head on over to teddyfresh.com we
still have 30 to 50
off the entire website here you can see
everything that's still in stock
uh conveniently placed on the home page
for you here's the hoodie i'm wearing
big ass chenille hoodie boy
title it like that what this stuff
a big chanel hoodie why you think it's a
bad name
no i'm just thinking it's funny to hear
you say it the big-ass chanel hoodie
yeah it was me i titled it
yeah i saw a really funny post on the
teddy fresh subreddit they go
i saw that ethan and eela might have
kovit is that why my package isn't
getting here what
and it had like 30 uploads people were
like yeah that's because like i'm not
you understand i'm not fulfilling
packages
you see me here on the podcast when
would i be fulfilling packages
you know the company the company does
not stop um operating when we're sick
thank you though for your concern
today's episode oh and then yeah today's
episode is sponsored by
roman and harry's razor all right
how's everybody doing out there
hopefully not as
concerned dan are you as anxious as me
because i know you're politically active
in too uh not as anxious i mean i
certainly
am uh you know annoyed and perturbed by
all the people saying the election's
being stolen or whatever but um
i don't know the people that are all
saying this they're all
political figures that it is important
but they're
they're not really the ones that are
going to even decide the election you
know
i'm not worried he's going to lose i'm
worried about the dam the corrupt
you know the eroding of the institutions
i mean i'll give you a stat
i told that i saw this yesterday and i
pulled it up um
uh they did a poll of like who's buying
this whole narrative
that uh the elections of fraud or
whatever and as of now
only three percent of americans no way
only three percent think that trump
won no 13 think the election is still to
be
tbd really yeah so i mean it's
it's something like um if that's true
something like 80 percent of republicans
are saying
biden one so if that's true then i
really need to get off yeah i think
i think it's i think it's definitely
over you really need to get off twitter
it's scary
i know i sound like i just was
brainwashed by the social dilemma but i
think it's true
no you make a great point either and and
i largely agree that it's
it's being amplified because it's
actually a small set of people that are
you're actually depressed by it like all
week
well you know i actually we had great
news but i don't want yeah i know we
have but like
i feel like they're i'm happy they're
doing so much damage
on the way out i'm happy yeah they're
going to do as much as they can
but they're out yeah you're right
bye-bye
the most compelling arguments i've seen
is just that they're doing all of this
so that they can keep fundraising off of
the rubes that'll give them money
yeah i thought i saw that they're
sending out mailers like
super mega guys they're trying to keep
the griff up they're trying to keep
people
feeling the way that you're feeling
essentially um so that uh
you know it can extract well i'm not
giving him money dan but
but the it's the inverse of the feeling
that you're feeling somebody that is
also
very upset by all of this but because
they think that trump won
i saw the mailer it was like this is the
last time i'm gonna
like mega guilt tripping like they're
doing a super hard sell and then the
fine princess 60
of this money will go to some random
[ __ ] super pac that
is gonna pay off the uh campaign debt
someone just donated a hundred dollars
to propose to his girlfriend bro come on
what is this what is this the baby wipe
[ __ ]
you could propose better than that you
did you not learn anything from me dude
are you gonna propose be a super chat
bro where is that super chat i
i just i put it in the discord i don't
want to do that dude trust me
there's better ways to propose i mean
wait i don't understand though why are
you one to talk because you have
i'm i am the one to talk because i'm
like didn't you learn anything from me
trust me there's better you could do
better it was in the the wipes right
yeah it was in a wipe zack it was
horrible it's my mom's
i mean this is better than the one you
think it is okay go ahead read it if
they're both loving the show and now
it's kind of better
okay go ahead you know if i was on when
you're like hey i just pooped okay
god you know it's funny though you know
what's funny though is that it worked
out
i think you're lucky that i hate a lot
of [ __ ] as much as you do
well i wouldn't for each other i
wouldn't have done it otherwise
i hate choosing proposals i knew that if
you cared about big beautiful proposals
i wouldn't have done
it that way you know that right i know
but still it was
it could have been better than that yeah
well they want your
i mean if i could get popcorn's blessing
all right so
you know if this was if this was a cameo
i'd be like listen uh
uh what's his name elijah listen elijah
i wish you you remember that guy who
kept the money and was like
yo elijah i wish you well but i don't do
but we're gonna have to talk about a
higher rate for this so anyway here's
your
camera thanks for the 100. i think it
was sean kingston
i think that was a guy that didn't know
i think yeah 100 bucks dude come on
we're doing a
all right here we go hi ethan and ela my
name is elijah and i'm not doing this
because of any
clout pills it was recently
my girlfriend kaylee speed
i can't really read it you have this
chord too
so you don't need to write on my left
say what you can read it on your laptop
i need that clout
where's discord here [ __ ]
all right is my my girlfriend kayla's
bday and we are avid viewers of all your
shows and videos you guys are our real
life relationship goals and was
wondering well if that's the case then
maybe this is a good
proposal could i get papa's blessing to
ask her for her hand in marriage it
would mean the world if you guys could
you get her to call in maybe
yeah you mean the world you guys could
shock her with this question
on stream well i think we kind of ruined
the surprise
yes y'all are definitely invited to the
wedding since soflo is my father
all right elijah let's get this guy on
the phone let's see how the
proposal went let's see please
let's see if she said uh yes
wow that's beautiful
um
all right in the meantime should i wait
for this
or let's do it in the meantime yeah
we're looking right now it might take a
minute
congratulations maybe she said yes maybe
she said no
we'll find out soon there is a george
something saying you sound like my
boomer mom
worried that trump will somehow reverse
no i'm not
i'm not your boomer mom and i'm not i
know that he's going to be the president
you you understand i know he's going to
be the president
you just think about that is is very
damaging
it's just that the fact that there's a
whole
side of a political party that can just
like openly
i think that um he's already been doing
it for like four years no but
all these people are enabling him now
which they have been doing but it's like
oh my god
it's just so and undemocratic like hello
this is [ __ ] america dude
we don't have presidents questioning the
like
biden won by a lot by the way he won by
a lot
a lot a lot all right i don't talk about
this [ __ ] anymore nobody [ __ ] almost
listed me cry
you know but when there's tanks in your
neighborhood just remember i was right
and i'll be in new zealand by then
[Music]
because i was like it's ethan versus the
algorithm
you think i'm just fighting the
algorithm you're so well killer
i was right about covid i could be right
about anything
i told elish i was like i was like
true patriots want to stay and fight
true patriots want to stay and fight
to make the country better i go
not me i'm going to new zealand because
this [ __ ] whenever this [ __ ] goes
somehow the jews always end up [ __ ]
dying first
serious you know that's true
one way or another the jews are getting
roasted and i'm going to [ __ ] new
zealand to rattle my dags
i grew through the depression thing i've
been so [ __ ] depressed about it
there you go you are talking i'm so
[ __ ] depressed
like what about just everything
like covered numbers are up and the
clovis [ __ ] is so depressing oh my god
it's so [ __ ] scary hey zach can we
talk about your big uh
your love interest yet or not
maybe not after the [ __ ] that was on the
sub what was on the side
oh there's just there's a full-on
revolution against that that's being
cancelled see i feel like i didn't do
anything
i had no like it was pretty pretty i had
a pretty
peaceful week and i just wasn't on
anything
i didn't look on reddit yeah but before
zach he's not using it
what's happening yeah well do we have
some media to talk about it so we can we
can discuss because i actually didn't
prepare to talk about it
it's not then okay no i wanna what are
they saying zach
they're i mean they're saying i'm a
creep they say that
they feel unsafe to listen to the shot
unsafe what is he gonna crap through the
moderator
and it's like it's really i've never
experienced any hate like that before
yeah it really
[ __ ] sucks yeah but
i'm just going to keep doing me but
it it just the fact that people would
call me that
like i'm a creeper it really just
[ __ ] hurts all right let me say
something
for for zach first of all zach
is dedicated to this show
and he plays up what he knows i like and
thinks funny
zach plays up the whole creep angle
because it's funny
and that adds texture to the show he
wouldn't
zack's been here a long time he's just
started to feel comfortable
on and play this up you guys how are you
gonna he hasn't done anything
except make some creepy jokes
like yeah maybe i always felt like maybe
i mean
maybe some of the jokes are creepy but i
kind of take it as a joke
you know i don't that's a good dude he's
golden and true
but i don't think zack actually treats
women wrong or
you know or anything like that i don't
know what they're worried about
and they think that he's actually you
think he's out there
you think he's out there roofing girls i
don't
it's just i mean he lives with his
parents for christ's sake
was he gonna roofie someone exactly look
i like to be honest
and say like yeah i've tried this
or like this is a funny experience
and but the fact that people would say
that [ __ ] about me
yeah you because the whole chat right
now is saying exactly we love you
yeah i don't know if you're reading the
chat but zack the thing is but it sucks
for you to go through it because um
it's really difficult and right
there isn't really any way to prepare
for such a thing
we've been dealing with that our whole
career for years and years and years but
you've
but you haven't dealt with a bunch of
people who don't know you hating you
yeah so it is very tough yes it's very
hard probably the most difficult thing
to
handle i feel like yeah and you don't
have like the tools that maybe we've
developed over years
yeah to handle it so like if i was a
creep you think i would hide that
like why would you you know like i gotta
tell you guys to the listeners if i
thought it was a creepy wouldn't be
working with us
yeah i thought it was a bad dude do you
guys think that i'm okay with creeps
and that's that's the first thing that
i'm not okay with if there's anything
i'm not okay with
right is men being creeps yeah you know
start playing stop starchily trust me
staunchly anti-creep
i don't like any of that kind of
attention from men and i don't
and that's probably why i dress the way
i do i don't ever wear like cleavage and
that kind of stuff because
that's the that's the number one thing
that i probably hate the most
is creepy man hey baby talk to me baby
um if i thought zach was a creepy man he
would not be working with us
i i but you know i was in i got even
some heat on the sideline because uh
we were having a debate and i said more
people should be like zach and i saw
people being like [ __ ] for
say you know for the record i didn't me
i don't think people should be creeps i
meant people should be themselves
yeah that's what i meant is that i'm
bracing zach being himself
so so on one hand let's let's
acknowledge why people are upset
yeah there's a lot of girls who are
watching or guys i mean i'm not going to
say
say but i think it's mostly girls who
are saying
that some of the conversations makes
them uncomfortable
and i acknowledge that it makes you
uncomfortable but i do want to just
say that it is it is theater what we're
doing and i think it's funny i like the
extreme
personalities and so i i encourage it
from zach because i think it makes the
show better
and i think it's okay you know i think
maybe it's even good if you feel a
little uncomfortable i mean you know
you can be the judge of that but i think
it's more engaging content
when you have this kind of friction and
these strong characters right
and that's why i love what zach's been
doing for the show well i appreciate
that and one of the first
few things ethan and ela and i related
on was like
stern and that style of comedy yes
and that's what i grew up with and
if i can be honest as i can and you know
accentuate that a little more than
exactly but like i look you can think
i'm you know
you don't have to agree with everything
but to say i'm a creeper
like i would i would treat someone like
that like that's just [ __ ] up man
well they call you a creep but then they
go in it's not like because people are
like oh zack's a creep haha it's funny
but then they write whole essays about
how it really
and you guys it's you know i'm sorry
that it made you uncomfortable but at
the same time
you know and i feel like the thing is
that um maybe
some of your jokes maybe i could cringe
at them but i think that's funny
you know like that one uh the one the
the trap got him yeah that one that was
like that was a great
moment obviously that's really dumb
things to say
what you said that she doesn't even have
an ass but
i always cared who cares it's a stupid
joke yeah we cringed at it
it was like you know but that's kind of
like
part of what's funny here anyway yeah
exactly
it's kind of epic though you're the
first cast member i think to
really get that intense amount of [ __ ]
and if talking about howard stern people
hate all the cast members so i think
that's pretty good
yeah so that's kind of a milestone that
people care enough about you to hate you
right
i mean it's the howard stern method
people are gonna listen to hear me and
the haters are gonna listen two times
more
to see what i say next you know i mean
that's just
i think they won't listen but that's
okay
we're getting tons of donations saying
zach we love you so much
yeah that's the thing is before people
went like
well there's an action figure of the
beer barbecue
that's hilarious um i was trying to find
like what is that poster you guys are
talking about
the was there a big one it was after the
last uh
after dark so it's kind of old yeah but
but i think we covered it pretty well
oh thank you dan you got some hate a
while ago about your like comments about
bill gates and stuff right
yeah people didn't like all right okay
and we all got no it was me
yeah that was good i stand by that
stance [ __ ] dan's like a
dan's a communist so he gets paid from
capitalists
when are you going to revolt against me
dan
you play you got to say i haven't been
undermining you from day one dude yeah i
know it feels like it sometimes
thank you dan all right let's talk about
i actually have a [ __ ] show to do
here
i i appreciate the advice guys i do well
we love you what can you do yeah
zach you ain't and also sometimes not
every joke is gonna hit you know
like zach is not necessarily an
experienced um stand-up
comedian it's not what you're doing you
know
just doing our sound levels to being
a character on the show so that is how
we take it sometimes maybe some of the
jokes are like you know
a little cringy or a little weird or
i don't know but that's funny it's like
yeah zach
it's it's a it's a very small minority
and i hope that the people who are upset
just you know take it with a shot of
[ __ ]
uh penicillin is an anti
penicillin is a day
it's a uh antibacterial penicillin right
yes i believe so there you go
sorry i don't understand shut up siri
you don't understand a lot you're a
robot
all right should i do has it really been
30 minutes
i got to do an ad well i mean
listen i gotta i gotta do an ad here
let's do one now
roman let's get all you young all you
guys out there who need some help
on your deck
it's awkward embarrassing to talk about
your erectile dysfunction usually we
brush it off or blame ourselves but
roman is here
to get you the advice you want and to
help you
with no shame how
many times you use an excuse like i had
a long day at work
i'm just not feeling it it isn't easy to
talk about erectile dysfunction but
roman makes it easy
and we treat that e.d boy
let's get those dicks hard
like they you know a man just ain't the
same unless he can get a
hard dick and i and i truly do believe
that because it's just
it's so important to the psyche of a man
you know i
i went through times in college where i
had anxiety
i had really bad anxiety as you guys
know in college and sometimes i couldn't
get it up i'll be honest
and it's just it as a man when you're
and you
it's really the worst when you really
want when you're with somebody and you
really want to do that with them
and you can't i mean that's just one of
the worst things in the world as a man
women you could just throw some [ __ ]
olive oil on there some mayonnaise
lube whatever you know but whatever's in
the kitchen whatever's around whatever's
at arm's length
talking about great jokes this is the
show you guys signed up for
and we're going to criticize zach
[Laughter]
don't you find it a little unfair though
that for a woman all you got to do is
throw some vaseline on there
you want to talk about fair when did you
have your last period right
yeah that's a good point and you peace
standing up anywhere you want
okay sorry i mean i'm just talking about
one aspect of the gender
and wasn't committing full-on war with
you
man but with guys if you can't get it up
there's no game there's no there's
nothing to do there's no lube that's
going to help that dick grow
and that's why roman is so important you
can go to with roman you get a free
online evaluation
and ongoing care for ed all from the
comfort and privacy of your home
a healthcare professional will work with
you to find the best treatment plan
if medication is appropriate roman will
ship you real medicine with free two-day
delivery the whole process is
straightforward
simple and discreet getting started is
simple just go to
getroman.com h3 complete an online visit
and complete an online visit erectile
dysfunction used to be tough to talk
about but now there's roman
complete an online visit today to
connect with a doctor and take care of
it just go to getroman.com
h3 to get 50 off your first month of ed
treatment a free online visit and free
two-day
shipping that's getroman.com h3 for up
to 50
off your first month of ed treatment get
roman.com
h3
i'm not i'm i'm not embarrassed to admit
that i have i used
i've had you know erectile dysfunction
problems from my anxiety
it's horrible too it's good i mean you
shouldn't be the embarrassed it's a
medical thing yeah i mean at the time i
was human i was humiliated and
embarrassed and
the thing is like it makes when you get
when it happens once
then you psych yourself out and then it
it like all keeps happening it's [ __ ]
horrible
it's like dude come on bro we used to
have an understanding like we used to be
dogs we should be best friends
like you always were there for me and i
was there for you and now all of a
sudden it's you're on the bench
man it's a scared turtle
you know it's just it's just [ __ ] up
like damn dog really
judas betray me now you betray me now
oh no never go against the family
listen never go against the family again
you know what i'm saying it's just it's
not right okay
we get it do you
you want to talk about harry's stop fair
enough
harry's razors we love harry's razors
because they are they got that close
beautiful shave that smooth glide
and it's just so convenient to get
shipped to your house new us customers
can redeem a harry's trial set
of harry's by going to slash h3
you'll get everything you need ela for
one two
three dollars three dollars
three dollars harry's dot com slash h3
how are they paying for this ad read
right now
dude it's just goodwill bro they just
pay with goodwill
[Laughter]
they crunch the numbers you know what i
mean they you know they'll get you
they'll get you somehow they know that
honest value harry's was founded by two
friends jeff and andy
who were tired of overpaying for razors
they thought most big brands were
oversized overpriced not a touch
so they founded harry's as a return to
the essential quality blades at an
honest price as low as two dollars
per refill come on quality german
engineered blades harry's founders
wanted to sell products that they were
proud of so they raised a bunch of money
to buy a razor factory in germany
it's been honing precision razor blades
for 100 years
they sourced their steel from sweden so
exotic
is made in germany it's sourced in
sweden
and owned the entire manufacturing
process from r d to the factory floor
this allows them to keep the prices low
harry's is delivering their sharpest
shave ever and they aren't raising
prices their new blade is so sharp
that you could i won't make a joke about
murder
they probably wouldn't like that their
new blades are so sharp
that guy's shaving their privates might
no i won't do that
their new blades are so sharp the guys
shaving four times per week reported
that with harry's new
blades their eighth shape was as smooth
as their first
whoo they're
they confidently stand by their blades
with 100 money-back guarantee
on harrys.com it's available everywhere
you shop
so we have a great offer for our
listeners you us customers can redeem a
harry's trial set at harry's dot com
h3 for just three dollars you'll get a
five blade razor
featuring their new sharper blades a
weighted ergonomic handle
ergonomic is one of the most satisfying
words to say i don't know why
isn't it ergonomic
ergonomic i don't know it means it fits
your hand though it's like such a cool
work it means it fits your [ __ ] hand
bruh
yeah maybe maybe i just
maybe i just like things that fit my
hand perfectly so i like the word
aerodynamic
because it makes me feel like i've got a
perfect hold on something
interesting deep thank you so much
where was i ergonomic handle foaming
shave gel with alloy
and a travel cover aloe
[ __ ] alloys a metal everything
hallow is a plant that gives gel that
you like
aloe and a travel cover to protect your
blade when you're on the go
with lead there's no lead in it
they said aloe so just go to harrys.com
h3 redeem your trial offer today okay
can we start the show now
36 minutes in let's go all right so
um so there was this
twitter you know you know i was so in
love with
um what happened
at the total landscaping or wait that we
haven't even talked about that god
there's so much to go over
oh yeah the uh four seasons total
landscaping we have two of my favorite
stories of the year
easily maybe even the decade let's be
honest
the first one is this guy dean browning
who is a former
uh what was his uh
he was a some kind of state congressman
yes
he was some kind of elected official in
the state of pennsylvania and he's some
maga guy
so he tweeted out what trump built in
four years biden will destroy in four
months
you know it's funny when i first read
that i didn't know if it was uh positive
or negative
i was like that sounds good anyway
so somebody said you mean what obama
built in eight years trump trying to
take credit for for the blah blah blah
some [ __ ] uh you know
arguing on twitter so he responds
i'm a black gay guy and i can personally
say that obama did nothing for me
my life only changed a little bit and it
was for the worse everything is so much
better under trump though
i feel respected which i never do when
democrats are involved which
he's you know as a black gay man myself
i found a little surprising
he clearly um forgot to switch out of
his uh
burner account you know the thought of a
grown
ass serious man who has a burner account
of a black
gay man oh my god just so he can leave
comments like this
is really something isn't it it's just
that's crazy but i love that he outed
himself and then immediately you know
everyone was like
oh you know he started quoting and
tweeting and screenshotting and then
so this guy you go down this rabbit hole
it's
never ending i mean it the story gets
better and better right like
so first of all they found his burner
account dan purdy
somebody found his burner account i i am
assuming because they went through all
of his tweets and found like the one
gay black guy who was always posting
maggot [ __ ]
and supporting all his tweets so this is
him i'm a gay black guy who doesn't like
the way black men are treated
treating this country black women are
treating this country oh really
now you're a white dude
with a burner account i'm black and gay
bro why are you do you really just want
i think this guy's just
really wants to be black and gay
this guy identifies tell me who is gay
i'm black and gay and i live in that
world now where do you live
you know this and this is just one
ticked off white dude in pennsylvania
imagine what russia is doing
there's like a billion black gay people
in russia on twitter
my black gay ass will be first in line
on tuesday when i re-elect donald trump
[ __ ] it's funny how every tweety somehow
manages to put in the fact that he's
black and gay
well yeah otherwise you gotta establish
credibility
i'm black and gay and i finish find it
disturbing that you think your own
personal and biased name
yeah i can't even read it but he's gone
on and on and on about it
oh there's more he calls this guy a [ __ ]
epic greta here he is [ __ ] on greta
thundberg which is everyone's
every conservative's favorite pastime so
this is from the white
uh profile yeah that's that's that's
what he tweeted greta thundberg is
living proof that the first for
40 year old first 40 years of childhood
are always the hardest
bro you are on twitter
[Music]
sock puck bidding as a gay black man
talking about immaturity
someone says wow super classy to a
passionate young person
and then dan purdy comes in all the
leftists are mock-worthy even you know
that
okay dan purdy that's him
that's dean browning responding to his
haters
oh man here he is responding himself
boom
what you are transgender
this is crazy this is like the cringes
[ __ ] ever bro
like i said black woman will be the
death of america okay
dan purdy wow pretty odd coming from a
white guy
why is specifically a woman i don't know
man this guy's got some weird [ __ ] to
reckon with well there's a lot more
there's several more layers of twists to
this that
oh this tweet is so foul
i love the taste of black girl fear
always so laughable wow dude
yeah that's some like straight up
that's some likes this guy's so weird
he's gonna be a black gay man and he
really hates black women
yeah specifically he seems to be going
after a black woman
yeah how to hate myself for being black
she's a disgrace to the race
bro i can't this is getting hard to read
black power white guilt like
dude you are this guy's straight up a
clan member i mean
oh and then of course he shits on tim
heidecker's new show she thinks funny he
just goes boring
new york post posted a a review
i just had to throw that one in there so
weird that he just took the time to
so as you could tell this guy is a
straight up uh
closeted i mean slightly closeted racist
so what now
if we go deeper so everyone started
finding all these tweets from his
from his all account and being like wow
this is some weird and wild [ __ ]
so he you know he tries to explain it he
tries to explain it
this is when we get really interesting
he says regarding the tweet that is
going viral for my account
i was quoting a message that i received
earlier
this week from a follower sorry if
context was not clear
trump received record minority votes and
record lgbtq votes many people won't say
it vocally but do in private
okay so he's saying he got a message
from dan purdy
oh i responded it's me
i like my own tweet why not if not me
then who
if not now then when just don't tell me
you're gonna start retweeting yourself
no i'm just kidding
[Laughter]
um so you know that doesn't make a lot
of sense dude this guy
sent you a a a response why didn't he
tweet it himself
one and why did you send it in response
to a comment from your it doesn't make
any sense bro
it's crazy it's crazy talk but wait
hold the phone oh [ __ ] this
dan purdy is gone okay you guys are
suspended but i backed it all up
so then all of a sudden dan purdy
whose original account got banned i
don't know why do you know why i got
banned we got suspended because
he's racist well maybe that it probably
got mass
reported also he's pretending to be
somebody that is not so
as we'll find so then guys
to make matters more interesting dan
purdy puts out a video
and this is it hey guys
my name is dan purdy and i am indeed a
gay black man
the message that you saw on dean's
twitter was posted
i don't actually know how it was posted
but i didn't send it to him because i
had a problem
with how are they just i love how
they're just glossing over like
yes he posted on him his personal
account and i don't know how that
happened we don't understand how that's
possible yeah none of us do
it's such a desperate attempt to save it
bro you just got it just reminds me like
i don't know if you ever
texted someone by accident something you
meant to text someone else
and then you're like desperately try to
like oh like come over
you're like come over to someone you
don't want to see and they're like cool
and you're like no no no not you
this is a total streisand effect i'm
trying to explain the [ __ ]
i think the best thing to do would just
be disappear from twitter for a month or
two
you know but here we go dan purdy nobody
understands how it happened
my race and sexual persuasion are
treating donald trump
i don't have a problem with donald trump
sexual persuasion i don't that doesn't
sound like the right way to describe
that
you think it's fine okay
all right and i don't understand why so
many pretend to
donald trump has never done anything to
hurt me either as a gay man or as a
black man
nor has he yet hurt anybody in the four
years that he's been in office because
he hasn't had time to
so what's the big deal i sent that
message to dean
dean accidentally posted it somehow what
the [ __ ] and that's the end i
accidentally posted it it's just a butt
dial it doesn't make any sense
this whole diet this whole narrative is
just so odd he accidentally posted it
somehow
no he's not a sock puppet no i'm not a
bot
i hope you understand we don't
understand
everything is clear now so okay then
people go
okay who who is this guy so then all the
internet
detectives in the world start snooping
on who is this guy
um they figured out who he was of course
so here we go let's go let's figure out
what's going on here
from googling it would appear that down
browning's black
guy identity dan purdy was also used on
the suspended account soul cookie
but before that account became dan purdy
it was a white guy named pat
ryerchy and white goodman dean is really
so wait i don't understand this
explanation though
they're saying before he was pretending
to be damn party the black guy
he was some other wife yes he had a
different sock puppet identity as i'm
using the same
pictures and using the same profile
picture
yeah well if you've done this once
you've definitely done it more than once
i mean this guy's old enough he's
probably been doing this his whole life
uh he's probably in aol chatrooms trying
to get kids to kill themselves or
something you know what i mean
psycho someone figured out okay so
so the thing is is that that points
towards the dean
having previously used that profile
picture
of the cartoon guy bile holt
okay you recognize this guy yeah it's
the same guy
so they found out who this guy is right
and then it gets weirder
still he is the son of this singer
she's a famous singer he's her son oh
what
like he's kind of like a public figure
what
which is yeah which i'm assuming he
didn't think anybody cared about him
which is true but once you figure out
his name you see him with his mom who's
famous
all over the place okay and then you
keep the bell just for real patti
labelle yeah i wasn't sure
okay okay so
oh she's he's adopted son and nephew of
music legend patti labelle
he's written a bunch of articles okay
thank you zach
so here here he is again so they figured
out this guy
his real name is not dan purdy dan purdy
and everybody no no he's not dan purdy
his name is his name is
bile holt what yeah he's not damn pretty
and he lives in pennsylvania right they
really didn't think the internet would
uh
yeah i mean the guy he's an old [ __ ]
boomer using sock puppets as a gay black
man the guy didn't know anything
about the internet so he's clearly just
a friend of this guy
right in pennsylvania and this dude was
like yeah sure i'll make a video
i'll be i'll be uh yeah he called him up
real quick and he was like listen i need
your help i need you to just
record me a video taking the heat for
this say
say you're dan purdy and send it to me
so i can prove
that it's really uh so now this poor
bastard is so
crazy his got mixed up in the drama
so what does so the human uh this
compete in my basement
exactly oh well it could be worse you
could just be peeing in your basement
like the quartering so
in real life they're just friends this
too well
that's what i'm going to assume because
how else would he get some random dude
a gay black man even it's interesting
that he had that on speed dial
yeah listen you're the only gay black
man i know so
so i think it's in the duck there's
there's one more layer to this
well that guy is kind of i don't want to
call him a
local celebrity but just like a known
personality
in that area and one big thing is people
dug up he's got all he had like a blog
that's basically it's it's kind of like
it's like the quartering it's like
culture war like
yeah so he does share the ideals i think
right exactly
which kind of explains why the end of
personal liberty
garbage feminism and television
black facing in hollywood why is disney
oh well that one's kind of woke
uh and ant i don't know whatever who
cares
the point being is you can imagine you
can imagine a world at which these guys
are friends yeah they roll in the same
circle
okay which is apparently uh what's the
problem with ozark
ozark an anti-feminist review let's see
when a woman kills a man on television
these days it's always a red flag for me
huh okay and when it happens multiple
times in the shame show i know
i'm watching a product of the dreaded
feminist conspiracy to destroy maleness
in hollywood
whoa dude you've been thinking a lot
about that that said as a man i must
report that i feel deeply disrespected
snowflake alert by the second season of
netflix ozark
that's your boy so that was wild that
was fun
deep undercover no yeah
i just been in my basement the
quartering is deep undercover as a human
being
[Music]
he's actually just a
he's a people he pees in his basement
he's a man if he's in there
okay that was fun that's my favorite
that's my second favorite
somebody in the chat asking so does dan
purdy exist or not the answer is no
dan purdy does not exist sorry if that
wasn't clear
the great dan party
[Laughter]
dan purdy does not exist so my second
favorite or that was my second favorite
story of the year my first
favorite story of the year you know i
kind of realized that even with
how much i know about the like social
media and the internet i still
probably am way too naive because when i
would have seen that
comment from like someone with like a
black profile
i wouldn't really doubt that it's a
white man yeah why would you pretending
to be a black guy
i mean you can't comment about that you
can't walk around in the world just like
doubting everything you see yeah but you
got to know there's a possibility and
people are getting more advanced with it
because there's now all these
ai generated like face generators oh
yeah
they used to be able to like hide behind
a cartoon avatar or something right
but now you can actually get a person
and you know you try and search
you know you reverse image search that
person's profile picture and it doesn't
show up
because that person doesn't exist it was
made by a computer somewhere so yeah
i've seen this
i can't believe anything these computer
generated faces look
so [ __ ] real i mean it's a real
person they just don't know
people that are good at forensics and
stuff at this point still
i think can figure it out from little
clues but if at a glance you'd never
even think twice about it it just looks
like a person
so my my number one favorite story
question who's on my shirt
it's who's that myself what's going on
dude elaborate bootleg louis thoreau
where'd you buy that
on etsy you're not supporting uh i'm not
but i am supporting the message
which is that louis thoreau rules yeah
that's hot
thank you will smith
oh there was no you've got no uh rewind
no rewind we were just talking about it
last week right
and we were saying didn't we say there
shouldn't be one
they probably watched our show and
responded to us
oh no i'm kidding that's crazy that they
just dropped rewind i mean
i guess that's what we get for being
such a douche [ __ ]
stay in community you know what i mean
like you know what's funny it was the
rewind fortnight 2018 that everybody
[ __ ] hated and had a meltdown about
mm-hmm we still quote it we still
people would say this is so cringe just
the worst rewind room ever
every single show yeah it's the best
rewind i can give it
the best content i can say that now it's
the best rewind
by far by far and the k-pop quote we got
all kinds of sound bites
by far evergreen but this is what we get
we can't have nice things and youtube is
like you know what
[ __ ] you and good for them they're like
[ __ ] you guys do you guys suck
like the youtube community is just a
bunch of ungrateful [ __ ]
and i understand that youtube isn't
perfect and i've complained i've i've
had my share of complaining about
youtube but it's like
compared to everybody else you want
compared to facebook bro
can you imagine um just from the
perspective of someone who's working at
youtube
it's like it's just a job for them right
but like everyone hates you
everyone hates youtube yeah anything
they do gets
negative all political sides hate you
any everything they do
any blog post whatever you do we hate
you
you know everything they do is to
preserve the this delicate ecosystem
that
the fact that even exists is a miracle
right that we can just come here and
make money and put out content
yeah so
youtube appreciation uh moment how come
you don't want me man
what was it i do want you i do want you
youtube
that was the will smith uh sad from uh
so
my favorite favorite story of the year
okay and i feel like nothing will top
this i can confidently say
four seasons total landscaping
okay i'm gonna start off by playing this
bbc uh
report because they do a really good job
of explaining it
for those of you that aren't familiar
and when his campaign was
done and then we'll talk about it
trump's defeat was announced while the
president was playing golf and when his
campaign was setting up in a gardening
firm's yard
just by an adult bookstore and a
crematorium
this story starts with donald trump
tweeting that there would be a press
conference on saturday morning at the
four seasons in philadelphia
people assumed he meant here the four
season's hotel
but another tweet followed with a
clarification no not the hotel
but four seasons total landscaping a
gardening company in an industrial area
on the outskirts of philadelphia
the washington post took in the arc of
donald trump's presidency with this
story headlined
it began on a gold escalator it may have
ended at four seasons total landscaping
the article quotes the company's
director of sales i have no idea why the
campaign wants to do it here
maybe they saw a satellite image that we
have a big back lot and proximity to
interstate 95 well
whatever the reasons the trump campaign
had made its decision and
set up in the yard as you can see from
these pictures it was a low-key affair
a sign attached to the wall a podium
some journalists some trump supporters
a few doors down the adult bookstore
fantasy island and just across the
street from the local crematorium
and it was here that president trump's
personal lawyer rudy giuliani learned
that his man had lost what was it called
by
all the oh my goodness all the networks
wow all the networks
we have to forget about the law judges
don't count
well richard hall a journalist for the
independent was there he wrote this
article which starts
it began with a tweet from the president
it ended with his personal lawyer in the
parking lot of a landscaping company
struggling to be heard over a man in his
underpants shouting about george soros
and here's how he described that final
moment i think it was around
five minutes before mr giuliani came out
that someone one of the journalists
called
announced that the race has been called
and then journalists started to leave
this
this big press conference that had been
called by the president as lawyers
so it's a very strange scene and then
out on the street immediately outside
you had people starting to celebrate and
trump supporters clashing with biden
supporters it was it was a very strange
place to hear the result
remember to draw attention to the trump
campaign's claims that the election has
been stolen
no evidence was offered but more broadly
it certainly drew attention
two days on the event of the four
seasons continues to generate stories
from
politico usa today the atlantic south
china morning post the list
is a long one but credit where credit's
due the philadelphia enquirer has been
doing a lot of the heavy lifting on this
story
publishing a detailed account of the
whole thing it tells us
the 78 year old employee manning the
counter at the fantasy island sex shop
said the phone had been ringing off the
hook since saturday with callers asking
is rudy giuliani there well the team at
four seasons total landscaping appears
to have taken this in their stride
in response to criticism online it's
posted on facebook saying it would
proudly host
any presidential candidate's campaign at
our business maybe it will become a
fixture in pennsylvania politics
it's certainly been quick to see an
opportunity go online now
and you can buy a range of make america
rake again
and lawn an order
quite reasonably make the most of the
attention it remains unclear whether the
trump campaign booked the whole thing in
error or not either way at 11 24 on
saturday morning
america reached a historic moment cnn
announced joe biden as the
president-elect
donald trump played golf and his
campaign was in a car park by
fantasyland
this is the best yeah the way things and
the way it all lined up there how they
showed it the three things that were
happening at the same time it's just
like
you couldn't write it any better no you
couldn't even even imagine
as a comedy writer i don't think you
could even conceive
of the like that's that's straight out
of like always sunny in philadelphia or
like uh
an episode of curb or something i mean
it's just so bizarre
that you you thought you were booking
the four seasons hotel
but you actually booked four seasons
total landscaping on the outskirts of
town and their parking lot
and then on top of that even so it
started with trump saying
oh we're having a press conference at
totals four seasons
at whatever yeah so he goes
so he goes and then he donald trump
erases that
oh what is this big conference today
in pennsylvania yeah yeah look under
okay so he says
lawyers press conference at four seasons
pen philadelphia 11 a.m
okay and then he goes whoops i meant
four seasons landscaping whoops i mean
big press conference today and
philadelphia at four seasons total
landscape the president of the united
states tweeted out
four seasons total landscape
like now if you made the mistake why
would you go with
it and actually have it there that's
what blows my [ __ ] mind is that
rudy giuliani went to four seasons total
landscaping
put up some ghetto trump paraphernalia
on the wall
and said this is where we're gonna do
this it's just
it's just all too good and then he blew
it trump is just golfing
and then they both hear that everyone
called it that he lost
rudy giuliani is such a goon that would
happen like in a court
vonnegut book right that is very curious
totally
but like people wouldn't even know
unless trump tweeted the name
it would just seem like a random backlog
a backdrop it could have been anywhere
but they wanted people there for some
reason he the president tweeted out four
seasons total landscaping these guys
cannot even
book a [ __ ] event without
embarrassing themselves
and you expect them to properly run the
government
this is also why i'm not worried about a
coup taking place
i'm not i am not worried about a coup i
just want to make that abundantly clear
yeah thank you it's like they're not
they're not
they don't have it together enough to
pull something i feel so powerful
you know like the and then the fact that
like rudy
still went there knowing what it is
he went there rudy giuliani is such a
joke i've got some gr
oh did i close my donk [ __ ] i hate when
i do that
you know there's some great rudy
giuliani's just been on top of his game
lately and
and obviously the way it was uh the way
he got got
in the board movie did we talk about
that on the show
i think we did maybe briefly the thing
is i think borah kind of dropped the
ball on that one
he still got got yeah he got got but
like yeah well if he can be tricked by
by by borat he can certainly be tricked
by
any number of pretty much pick pick take
your pick
any government agency spy it's borat
we're talking about borat okay
pretty sure he has less resources at his
disposal than like
uh you know the russian intelligence for
example
but hey what do i know you know
um here's a google street view of total
landscaping
by the way even the name is like so
funny four seasons total landscaping
this is uh this is the spot i guess i'm
assuming it was in this park
[Music]
yeah it could not be any better why is
there four seasons in
in the title of this place they
definitely thought they were booking the
hotel
yeah yeah and then even the owner was
like we didn't know why they wanted to
have
their press conference here but we said
sure why not
well i make a i make a pledge to you all
today if i ever run for public office i
will announce it in the parking lot
four seasons called the landscaping
yeah you've been in a neighborhood like
this it's just like a total industrial
dump it's just a bunch of
seedy shops you know like there's a spot
like this in every town
here's the adult bookstore apparently
they have like little
booze i saw a video where someone went
in there it's like there's booths where
you jerk off and you bring coins
tokens i was like bro nice that's so
[ __ ] gross
you and would you jerk off in a
bookstore or adult bookstores
you got to do what you got to do
sometimes right
i guess make your calls i think it's
part of the thrill for them is they like
jerking off in the public
because there's no explanation otherwise
it's such a sad
situation though yeah
yeah i don't know if i'd necessarily
jerk off in that public of a setting but
yeah it's uh it's interesting
so that's that and then according to new
york times the mistake was not in the
booking button a garbled
game of telephones apparently giuliani
and trump campaign advisor
told their bosses they planned to hold
the news conference at four seasons
total landscaping
and he heard what he wanted to hear
which was fancy hotel chain
so i think what happened was they booked
it here not planning to announce it
right because they're like why would
they they just needed a lot
mm-hmm they didn't if if they never said
the name nobody would know
that it was in some [ __ ]
no no the reporters still would have
been no they weren't going to announce
the freaking location you know what i
mean
what was it for it's like they wanted it
to be a public event yeah
so this according to new york times they
planned it there all along
and when they told trump he what he
heard was oh it said the four seasons
and tweeted it out and then they're like
no no no no
four seasons total landscaping
i love it so weird the campaign had
always intended to hold the news
conference
in the in fact the time support the
command had always intended to hold the
news conference in a friendlier part of
town
uh the area around philadelphia
convention center where elected
officials have been counting absentee
ballots
but they were swamped by biden
supporters as to how trump's people
landed on four seasons total landscaping
both the campaign and the white house
declined requests for comment failing to
erase the impression that someone made a
large and hilarious mistake
yeah see i still think i think that they
just thought there was another there was
another four seasons yeah
close by and they were like let's just
do that one because out there and not
realizing it was a landscaping company
for sure here's the scene how much money
does she make
look i mean what the how much money does
she make
how much money do they take in bro why
are
you
in your pajamas it's very hard to get
accurate unbiased information
and what they did is they got them
fearful with corona and once they were
under a fearful state
they suppressed them uh and they they
funneled all the ballots through
all the voting through mailing where
they control that process
better and they can manipulate it better
for fraudulent activity
[Applause]
wow what a [ __ ] show it is there huh
holy smokes
it all goes down at four seasons total
landscaping
oh here so um
here is who's this cory
he tries to make it sound like a
respected institution the four seasons
he says all great americans in
pennsylvania use
four seasons total landscaping they love
this country and are american patriots
thank you
that's actually my favorite you know
what it's a scene from beep it's like a
veep scene where they're like
everyone's just trying to make this seem
like normal it's really like uh
roy purdy showing up trying to explain
roy birdie with it
i wonder if rooney went to the other
adult bookstore and rub one out
in the uh you wonder if giuliani went
there yeah i'm sure he did he might have
been stressed out
[ __ ] gotta unload a little bit bring
some toe tokens
some people are saying they've had
enough politics
well this isn't really politics is it
this is more like it's just
[ __ ] amazing like the office sort of
laughing
come on like a few days four seasons
every time we just heard the word
okay but uh here i'll fast forward i'll
fast forward to the to
so four seasons total landscaping is
made merch and why
why shouldn't they they totally should
yeah
we should buy some of these damn yeah
i'm a fan of for
since 1992 well established and then
separately because we're trying to get
off politics here
just so you know this is my this is my
one of my other favorite things
if a lawyer comes in wearing these you
are absolutely going to jail
here's rudy and [ __ ] whatever these
are
what are those rudy if your lawyer comes
in wearing these you are absolutely gone
i can't get enough of rudy giuliani why
does it look like a box
you know he's got roblox shoes
i have a theory that those are elevator
shoes like he has those that have lifts
in them
that's why they're making them super
short yeah i think it makes them taller
but why but can he get shoes that don't
look like [ __ ]
like 15th century like
yeah i think they're orthopedic
they look like medical shoes because
he's probably got a whatever
oh my god and then furries of course
made a vr hangout at total landscaping
this is the last one i was just browsing
my friends let's see who was where
this existed
[Music]
[Music]
very faithfully uh recreated it yeah
it's pretty realistic they probably use
google maps and just
and they worked fast on that
oh wow okay i'm done
for everybody who's over it what can i
do these are my favorite stories
it's not politics shit's funny no it's
fine
um rudy giuliani is literally a
character from always sunny
he's like the lawyer that's obsessed
with big hands you know
he's real he's a real [ __ ] veep
character
he's uncle jack yes he's uncle jack
all right we're done with paul maybe you
can read a few comments while i go
oh go ahead good great idea what you
gotta be
you got something for me okay i'm sorry
my
my camera just shut off for whatever
reason um
[Music]
let's see somebody's gonna make 50
dollars a b let's date
uh he's married so that's not happening
thank you for the fifty dollars though
he's married god damn it uh somebody
donated a hundred dollars says zach
doesn't deserve any hate much love buddy
damn dude i'm so happy i'm making money
for that you getting hate
this is great someone just gave me a
hundred bucks cause you got hate [ __ ]
sad let's get those hate threads going
keep it coming holy [ __ ]
uh hey papa ethan give zach this 100 oh
this guy's explicitly asking that you
give him whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
oh
alexander gave 100 give him a hundred
dollars tell him he's a king and i love
him
and all those people trolling him don't
know anything wait hold on was there two
one hundred dollars yes
oh there was so i get one and you get
one zack fair enough
we'll split ahead
we can go to the jerk booth yeah no yes
let's go we'll have dueling jerk-off
booths oh god
it'd be awesome they're not still making
like that's a vestige of like the 70s
like nobody's made a new jerk-off booth
since the internet was invented right
hopefully no yeah yeah there's no new
jerk off okay
no thank you thanks for the donations
what else dan
uh uh let's see
uh super excited for teddy fresh merch i
picked up front of the black
friday sale i channeled this hype into a
sweatshirt mock-up
fan art would love your thoughts on it i
posted the link in the discord send it
to
send it to one of the boys that's the
way to head it on over send it to the
boys
you know chet's back chat
then our boy chetna
is back with um he has his own thoughts
on the election
president so we should show some which i
thought were really
uh great to be honest i'm a big fan of
tomic's
black sheep son chet he's actually
jamaican he's literally all the g
because ali g used to joke about how
he's from jamaica he's ollie g
that's awesome he's american ollie g hey
guys i just want to say that you know
like now that trump's leaving office i
think it's important to remember that he
was the president so we should show some
recite
pussycraft [ __ ] them ross donna
what is a pus what does a clot mean like
pussycloth i know that
i'm not jamaican and i so i apologize
towards you make an audience if this is
incorrect but
my understanding is all of those insults
jamaican insults that have clot clot is
like a
like a rag or like uh oh or a towel or
something and so
pussycloth yeah it's like a [ __ ] rag
it's like kind of it's an
oh yeah like a menstrual
thing i guess there's also like the
bumble clap thing
that was like a big meme like six months
ago yeah what is why i know this is
because if that means like
uh swipe or something that means
douchebag
is douchebag or [ __ ] because i
always hear boba clatton like you know
music and
hip hop and stuff so yeah i know it's
it's an insult i could be off base with
all that with my understanding
the direct translation is that it's like
an ass wipe or a or
something like that boss man biden
he's pretty good i wonder if i'd watch a
show of chet in jamaica
talking like that and see how he gets on
that'd be [ __ ]
sick he'd probably die in a day it's
actually really funny when he's
switching off between being normal
he's really good at it he's really good
really good at it
you think chet would call him i know he
saw
no he was upset at us yeah but maybe
maybe i'm turning the corner on [ __ ]
maybe i like him
yeah you know what i mean let's see if
we can get chet on i want to shoot a
show where he goes to
jamaica that would be so
entertaining you know you watch that
with tom hanks think of that show oh boy
we'd pitch it like son of the academy
award-winning
actor chet pussycloth
[Laughter]
let's quit me now sorry
his boss man biden might be yeah
favorite new drop and
did you sound like that boss man
dude i gotta say though like we were all
pretty happy and
this video hit hard i i thought this
video hit really hard it's actually
really funny
i think it's important to remember that
he was the president so we should show
some recite
pussyclass
what does [ __ ] those ross me what is
ross [ __ ] those ross i don't know man
i think he says nimrods no i don't think
so
[ __ ] damn ross rob would be
boss man
we
[Laughter]
can you try to get a hold of chat zach
yeah yeah i'll reach out
we should ask uh andrew santino he's in
his dms
yeah we did i decided not to talk about
that yeah that might me and angie
decided collectively not to
not to go too hard on poor chat gotcha
for my father but i'll just say
in short you know that um
[Music]
well he posted it chet's the one that
posted it
right i mean i i wasn't revealing
anything that wasn't no no chet stolen
the post
so so chet was uh
threatening andrew i feel bad though
it's so did andrew angie was really
a really mature and sweet about it and
he he but anyway chet saw our segment we
did about him with andrew
and uh he was really angry and he was
threatening
he was threatening andrew and angie was
being really peaceful
and and uh really sweet about it and
then chet
posted the dms on his instagram
and then he erased it and he was like
i'm taking a break from social media so
andy was like you know what i just feel
bad for him and
let's just let it go so i don't want to
go to art on chat we love chat
as a side note
on the tiger belly subreddit they
thought they were talking about
um bobby and andrew
yeah wait was he making fun of him on he
was he making fun of him with bobby
not that i know no i i think this was
right after our episode i think he was
referring to you just oh yeah he
he called me out in the dm's he sold
sell that fat [ __ ] to keep my name out
of his mouth tail
yeah but i guess it's open well bobby's
after that bobby's a fat [ __ ] too so it
could have it could have been either
i think i'm more i think that
encapsulates me more it was shortly
after our episode came out i i
no it was definitely i strongly suspect
it was you yeah it
definitely was i talked to andrew about
it
yeah but i i you know it's hard being
tommy's on you know
[ __ ] bumbaclot boss man
bossman tom eggs
[Music]
oh man those dms were insane i gotta say
though it was intense
he wanted to kill andrew and he's a big
guy too i feel like he could scrap
i feel like andrew could defend himself
he's pretty muscular dude
really chat looks like a big then i
think they'd have a good scrap
i think they'd have a good old gold
scrap yeah i think they'd have a good
fight where's the h3 podcast
pay-per-view fight
boxing match chad versus andrew
[ __ ] that'd be good man yeah man
all right so excuse me why
what you got a problem would you like to
logic complain
do you know that this is a podcast that
people listen to
yes that was very loud well i did it up
i did it away from the mind
should i do it more then was it away
from the mic uh yeah
i mean it wasn't right i guess it was
not away from my ear
so i found a new tick talk account that
i love
i want to show it to you guys this is
just an account that showed up
on my for you page on tick talk it's
just one of those pages where you're
just like whoa
i can't believe this showed up on my
page it's just a it's a pure gem
i don't know what's going on i don't
know
i don't know where he's from i don't
know what language he's speaking i don't
know anything about this guy
i've done quite a bit of um not research
but uh i've watched quite a few of his
videos i have some thoughts on it but we
should we should just watch
it i think he's iranian am i right i
think he's actually from turkmenistan
his dialect is kurdish oh
yeah i think he actually has a big
problem with iran
as we'll discover okay well here he is
um
doing his thing
[Applause]
can you imagine this is just on your
feed you're looking oh here's a tick
tock crane
here's some cooking here's some dogs and
then this [ __ ] shows up
yeah so that's just one that's actually
not the first video i saw of his that
was the second video i saw off his when
i went to his page
the first page i saw was him
congratulating joe biden on his victory
box
joe bison joe biden
this message from muhammad
[Laughter]
you have to heal your life is to ill
to you from now from today to
two years one year and six months or
two years new life after this one you
pass away
you go check the check up in the doctor
this message from muhammad khan again
foreign
good job for the usa for the pcsa into
you
you do pull down young for us
you wanna couldn't stank in a new
country
no more iran no more iraq no more turkey
no more soothing
foreign
so this is an important diplomatic
message for joe biden
this just showed up with my for you face
i was like
only on tick tock i mean this is this is
why i love checking out so after
watching several times
i i think i've actually narrowed it down
to i don't think he's actually
congratulating joe biden
oh he's not he's issuing some sort of
warning oh no that joe biden needs to go
to a doctor
because he's going to die in two years
time or a year
a year to six months to two years time
he's going to pass away
i did understand that right and i'm not
sure if he's
like cursing joe biden like or if he's
trying to warn him like he's had some
sort of
prophetic vision of how joe madden will
i love
his demise and he's trying to save him i
love how he says his full name
a few times like yeah this is a
like oh [ __ ] the comments are pretty
good couldn't have said it better myself
brother this man spoke in terms and
conditions
someone says he's put a curse on him a.b
do you have any insight as our resident
uh muslim uh
so i've asked a few different people no
one can understand really what it is
there's a few words he says i think what
he's saying is he's a he's a
he's a professor and something like he's
a doctor and it's his prediction that
after joe biden does all these good
things
in a year and a half he's going to die
oh you think that he's the professor
because i thought he was recommending
that joe biden go see some doctor
but you're saying no i think he i think
he is the word is
the word's a little off but i think what
he's saying is that i know
i know what i'm telling you in a year
and a half but you're going to do good
things before then
you're going to accomplish a lot so he's
having a vision so he's not against
biden
sounds like he's i mean sometimes he
sees great things in biden's future
it's great things but but also morbid
things but also
someone asked in the chat has joe biden
responded
joe biden has not yet responded but i'm
sure his advisors have seen the video
stay strong boys it's november no not
november you know i'm a fan of his
camera angles too the guy killed and
it's a lot like in your style
and you know there's there's more
there's more messages for what is with
that clown
yes
okay did you get anything from that you
just like a good guy
well i know overseas they smoke a lot of
cigarettes
so i'm assuming they had something to do
with messing with his voice
that's all i got why is everyone writing
the same thing in the comments everybody
says wally be okay
24 7 every day wally that's his that's
right that's like his catchphrase he
says it in a lot of what i cannot i
can't understand
anything i'm telling
he said something like coming at you 24
hours seven now what was it 24 i wrote
it down
joel biden joel biden
also he has multiple accounts this is
actually not his main account
this is this one with eight thousand
followers yeah there's a link in here
he has another account with like it was
like thirty thousand followers this
guy's prolific
yeah he has a lot of videos okay this
one has 90 what is this one this is
okay 24 7. oh i hear now i'm wake up
35 years later but with brain damage
could be me after getting like a car
crash
or something like you walk by my room
and it's just like
don't go in there theodore just leave
that alone
but this this honestly you know i used
to i used to hate obviously tick tock
hater but like
there's no platform in the world there's
never been an opportunity for someone
like this
to be seen for me to find someone's
account like this it's just fantastic
i love that breath that deep breath
hey trump if joe biden wins
you check your family go to russia i'll
go to
turkey government because every year
turkey the government they give you
10 million dollars last thing you go
to russia take your family to russia
because you work for the russia
you you
from turkey
is
of these turkmenistan flags along with
israeli and uh
american flags and most of his posters
oh he likes israel that's cool well he
seems to be very yeah
nice it's funny yeah it's like i'm
saying he's also very anti-iran i think
he
i think he doesn't like iran i feel like
i've seen many people like him like
i could imagine like more people like
him in the world
in israel there's more of him oh yeah i
feel like i feel like he could totally
be one of my neighbors then
i kind of thought he was i thought he
was israeli at first
i had neighbors that would if you gave
them a phone and tick tock this is what
you would get
oh my god yes a b you sound like you
do too oh yeah i thought this was my
uncle at first
yeah we could i mean we could totally be
related
on my dad's side that's amazing
i love him he actually speaks pretty
good english at that last one surprised
me
yeah oh
i hope joe's campaign saw this he has
useful information
did you find uh which one of these links
is the one with
his main account because i want you to
see right here
it's the very top one if you click the
very top link here
we can literally just watch every single
video on here
this is different what
that's what i'm saying i think i think
the other one might be stealing his
content this might be his real one
also this one has less views no but look
how many followers it is
yeah but the views are super super low
on it well because he uploads so often
those are probably
oh yeah those are probably yes okay 24
7 as well as 24 7 a day every day
they all have a phone number oh no way
every single one call me baby okay
oh my goodness
[Music]
just scroll for a while i want you to
just kind of see the uh
the volume you die
you wake up and this is what you see
[Music]
oh so you think that account was
stealing from him possibly yeah
this one has here someone has a lot more
followers
that's what but i don't see any of the
videos we watched here
i think that they are there i think you
just missed yeah you have to go deeper
well we gotta see a lot of these have a
lot of views
yeah that makes sense it throws me off
upon him like my arabic's bad but
usually i could piece together words
are you doing can you call this number
dan and see what happens
call the number one right now
[Music]
wait i'm sorry you guys do want me to
call it yes yeah call yes
okay what is it i can't see the numbers
oh god well
just pull it up on your screen it's uh
okay okay one sec baby's too excited
seriously my long lasting
[Music]
so what so i've gone back quite a bit
this is from
oh he doesn't make this is from june
already he's not that prolific
well look how you've reached the clown
section
i never clicked these ones what are
these
just vocal exercises all right you got
it
i think baby's ringing warm up hold it
back
what happened what was that a.b i got
his voicemail i told him call me back
oh you told him in arabic yeah i told
him
you speak arabic yeah not well i could
say like
greetings and stuff lena does right yeah
lena speaks perfect
that's awesome we gotta use that somehow
yeah
that's such a great that's so great but
you just said call me back in arabic
that was pretty slick
well i heard like
let's call him one more time i want to
hear his voice message
guys don't call him this is important
yeah nobody call him
here we go i'm excited
did you leave your number for him i'm
kind of afraid too
yeah well he already called him he's got
a smartphone i thought we were going to
use like a
like a computer to call him but amy's
out there putting his number on there
and [ __ ]
i want to i want to learn more about
this guy
[Music]
it's ringing now though it went straight
to voicemail last time okay
interesting you want to put it on a
speaker
oh it's just a standard voice
[Music]
i want to hear you speak arabic
um just say we we
appreciate the kurds we love the kurds
uh shukran for
the good content and we love the tickets
[Laughter]
so he doesn't like turkey and iran
the whole first video we watched was him
just cussing out like 10 different
countries
yeah i hope you get a call back dude oh
my boy
my boy uh since we're in the region i
guess
um he hit me with that new [ __ ] that was
[ __ ] extraordinary
[Music]
let me start
he got a fake this homie on the right
looks so
he acts the part so good he's like what
he's selling it dude don't you all
appreciate they got a fake phone up in
this [ __ ] that you could take a bite
out of
it looks real they got me
sorry
i love that guy man up to some good
stuff over there that part of the world
good titles coming from that part of the
world oh you know what
okay i saw this on tick tock and sorry
to get political but you all got to
admit
this is amazing i fact checked this and
apparently as far as i could tell
this is really trump's border wall this
really is trump's border wall
when i first saw this i said there's got
to be something else there's got to be
more to this
this is the border wall
are you sure they're not just trolling
what trolling
how like this is just some construction
site and they're they're
pretending apparently it was on john
oliver's show and if you think that's a
credible source of news he said it's
real all right
it doesn't surprise me to be honest with
you
better than we're able to someone said
this is more to keep the americans out
of
mexico
doesn't surprise me people don't really
care about the wall it's just
theater god
dirty today boy i've gotten i've been
getting emails
concerned for you about the gerd man
really good
yeah it's usually not that bad it's just
i think when i'm when i'm
talking and vocalizing a lot it kicks up
a lot of stuff well
i don't mean to worry you because i and
take this is a random email but
somebody was email me saying gerd
long-term can cause like
esophageals yeah i know about that
problems and cancer
very rare but i do know about that and
i've talked to a doctor about it
all right he says my i talked to a
doctor i was like you know
i'm worried because i don't want to get
through cancer from this he says
well in all my years as a doctor i've
never seen that before
okay that's good yeah when i worked at a
medical office and we
handle i handled the chronic care we had
over like
200 patients and the most common uh
chronic disease was gerd
and nothing serious out of any of those
patients at least
but it can cause throat cancer in rare
cases but i mean right
i mean that's that's a hell of a [ __ ]
way to die
from gerd [ __ ] that
but i'm doing all i can dan i mean what
the [ __ ] can i do
[Music]
just there's just people concerned for
you what can i do
what more can i do you don't chug a
coffee before the show
well that's not gonna help that's not
gonna prevent me from dying that's just
gonna make the show better
you know
[Laughter]
not a big deal got a bunch of donations
coming in go ahead
let's see uh
hey guys love the show i was just
wondering if ethan ever listened to a
podcast called the drunken peasants with
peace and love
it sounds familiar it sounds a little
familiar to me too but i
i can't say that i've listened to it no
i haven't listened to it but i've heard
that you can do it
uh simply one v said i felt bad for
hashtag sadzak earlier so i drew him a
little
bit of a thirsty portrait to use on his
instagram who should i send it to
discord and send it to zach
it's a portrait of him send it send it
to the big guy all right
uh let's see uh
ela will you ever make a teddy fresh
sticker sheet i'd also love to see a
wallet or a lanyard looking forward to
future drops and keep up the good work
the lanyard what is it a lanyard yeah
what is the lanyard that's actually
holds your keys
yeah it's to hold your keys oh my god oh
okay it's usually like braided or
something
they're really popular when we were
growing up
uh sent the link to the teddy fresh fan
art oh from earlier
okay thank you uh hi from montreal has
anybody on the team visited canada
before no i've never been to canada i
would you have and you're not the only
person on the show
just answering for myself where in
canada has anyone been to canada
no yeah
detroit people go to canada all the time
oh that's right yeah i've been to
montreal in montreal for like a week
montreal's nice i gotta say canadians
know at a party too
those guys know how to party how do you
know that zach what does that mean i've
part i've partied with some canadians
and they're they're a great time what
does that mean is just fun or they get
crazy drunk
they're just fun they they do things out
of the ordinary that an american person
wouldn't do and really
yeah it's a good time the hell did you
guys get up to
some weird chat classified information
yeah
i almost got jumped in canada i mean my
friends but
what not that interesting of a story
jumped
i had a very aggressive homeless person
in montreal
that i remember the most aggressive
homeless person i've ever encountered in
my life
he's like do you remember that encounter
yolo yeah i'm i kind of feel like we
even told you on the podcast maybe out
that way
i don't know he was like
i vaguely remember it
those are the best stories so i'm not
gonna tell it it's been a while
anything else because right what we have
up next is
everybody's favorite crazy wild
viral touch point two touch point oh
baby
this is taj point one it's better than
taj point oh cause it's me ethan i'm
better
funnier uh taj my nose sucks i hate that
[ __ ] show to be honest
like why you gotta go there i gotta do
this
well well
because got him
well i'm not trying to oh i don't think
taj cares what i think about him deal
what if he's a fan dude taj is a fan
yeah right
he's watching right now i mean it's just
it's like
it's better than ridiculous
ridiculousness i'll give him that
exactly yeah i'll give him that it's
better than ridiculousness
thank you well here's tyler's point one
what's my version of taj point oh anyone
got any good ideas because that's kind
of like the segment we're about to get
into
so what are you asking like i have a
funny internet clip show
what's the name of the show it's called
the h3 podcast no
no no no this is a segment name we need
to think of our 3.0
ridiculousness [ __ ] we need to brand
this
ethan's corner ethan's corner
i know something on like ridiculousness
absurdity absurdity absurdity
gerd corner we're not corners i don't
want a corner i'm not why are you
watching
the corner i know why is it porno do you
know it's such a dumb name it's like
some kind of it's because it's like the
internet
that's a real software update [ __ ]
ian what's the name of our show you've
been quiet today
calling on you now i i got nothing man
okay thank you that should be the name
yeah welcome back welcome back
welcome back to i got nothing thank you
how are you feeling ian are you glad to
be have broken out of the mortal bonds
of your
uh prison you're being imprisoned by ain
you're
back in your room how does it feel you
know i kind of miss it
kind of wish i was back in the you know
downside
you missed the downside up okay yeah it
was comfy in there i got used to it yeah
yeah it was chilling we could send you i
had no responsibilities
yeah if you got any shungite you could
put me back i can't
got it can get whatever you want you got
a guy you gotta shoot that guy yeah
yeah how about shungite the shungite
the shungite effect
the no spin zone the fupa zone any
there's any good they said
[Music]
okay well it's a work in progress until
then let's just call it big fat
[ __ ] hack no unoriginal hack reset
reacts to funny videos online
hack how about this hack comedian
respond uh reacts to
online funny videos
yeah 0.0 that can be the that should be
the highlight title right there
write that down
i love that i talk about hacks like i'm
someone to judge
hack like i'm some pure comedy genius
all right let's watch some dumb videos
all right interested in ian's beard
let's see ian's beard looking pretty
good ian any comments on the beard this
be
crispy my dude crispy crispy that's not
you put oil in your beer no no
i'm trying to get the keemstar thing
going on i think he's got a good
he's got a good look do you feel like
the longest wait i i forgot i'm not
eating yeah you gotta get out of here
yeah i was gonna say do you feel like
the longer and more pointy your bear
gets the less
empathy you have for human beings i
think it's more so
more detached from reality i think which
fit when i was in the downside up
um are you going to show me you guys
stay here are you going to do no shave
november or ethan what's
what's what's wrong oh no no i don't do
this [ __ ] i don't do the whole [ __ ]
why are you doing no nut i thought it
was no not
isn't it both no shave your make up your
mind people
you want me to not nut or you want me to
not [ __ ] is it just let your life
fall apart november don't do your
laundry november
that's every month for someone ian have
you noted this november are you
participating in that
uh you can only pick one
is anybody doing no not november is that
really something people don't
think i mean we're already living in
like pandemic november i thought people
i thought that was just a joke i didn't
know people
actually didn't nut for a whole month
i don't think there's a lot of people
there are definitely it's not like a
weird in-cell thing they think they'll
like if you hold
it up it's your vital energy your vital
energy
we made fun of it once on the show
before and we got a lot of emails from
people being like
no actually i haven't had enough well
i'd love to take a call three
three weeks and i feel amazing i'd love
to take a call from someone who's on a
no not
diet diet hit me up
dm me if you're not eating nuts and
you're not
nutting dm zach i'd like to hear from
you
ethan with your how do you like that you
look like the uh effort right in the
[ __ ] guy the guy like
the guy who would uh run on camera say
after right in the posting run away
no i don't remember that i said you
[ __ ] right in the position [ __ ] it
right in the [ __ ] guys i remember the
[ __ ] around in the pool i didn't
remember
we're the me master how did you know all
right let's watch some dumbass [ __ ]
hack
point oh hack point oh
i'm not okay with the name hack point
off okay well
you got a better one called guard point
now gerd point oh
i guess that's just a placeholder for
now yeah we'll workshop it
stupid unoriginal [ __ ]
response to online videos because he
can't make his own jokes
so dude this [ __ ] i just i
what is going on in in europe this
happened previously
with some famous painting where they did
it this is real
someone restored this statue in spain
and
now this is what it looks like
not kidding this is real i saw a picture
of it on the street
yeah i can do this okay here's your
here's a brush
there's a [ __ ] chisel chisel good
luck
you got to take that thing down at that
point you got to tear the whole building
down
here it is before and they're like you
know we could we could fix that up
it was perfectly fine we can fix that up
oh look at the lamb head too
he did the lamp real story yes it's a
real story
now this is what it looks like
look at the lamb head here oh and
there's another one that was missing i
guess
that's the new one looks weird yeah
weirder than this no
maybe it's not done i don't know maybe
it's not done
can we say maybe that's a possibility
it's not done
because it's like like i mean i would do
a better job than that yeah i'm like not
even remotely close
and i'm not artistic at all
but that's that's real i mean that's
what it looks like i seen pictures of
from people walking by i posted it
you know
there was that can you find pictures of
that painting that they they restored
that was kind of a similar thing
tasha is a genuinely great dude who also
manages to have a successful tv show for
10 years i'm pissing off
people here we go
josh did nothing wrong with papa okay
i'm sorry
taj right we love you taj
you take it back i love
taj daniel taj is a generally great dude
he's done nothing wrong
we love taj people donated to say that
um i think juan did yeah i hate taj
correct me
sucks donate me to to set the record
straight
uh here so this isn't the first time
it's happened i mean oh this is
okay this isn't actually the one i was
thinking of it's dan
there's another relatively recent one
though also
this guy i mean who is hiring these
people is this a 100
donation he's saying play the fire
safety video
oh this is the one i wanted to show for
yourself i'm laughing just thinking
about it
this is who's hiring these people
you know what i mean like this is what i
would do i'm not
oh what the [ __ ] what are they doing
and then here's one of jesus that they
restored like this iconic one that's
what's this is the one i was thinking of
i don't get it that's almost what that
makes sense to me
look at this
botched restoration that's putting it
mildly weird
annoying weird so it keeps happening in
spain in particular and
i was talking to my girlfriend about
this i guess in the art community
there's like conspiracy theory that
this is happening on purpose because
every time it happens people go
super viral and become like little mini
celebrities so people are going out of
their way to [ __ ] up
classic art to like get attention
essentially but who is hiring these
people
somebody owns this question they keep
saying it's like amateur art restorers
these are amateurs it must be somebody
with credentials who's just worse than
amateur
but i think i think the theory that it's
a it's a professional who's like [ __ ]
this
art because that's like you know first
grade
art i mean what the [ __ ] is that
okay horse balance you wanted the fire
thing i'll watch the fire thing but
first
i mean if you like the fire thing you're
gonna like this just as much
oh it's deleted what the f it was
deleted
oh no i just checked it this morning i
mean
um we could easily find a backup little
people erase posts it's so odd
this post was deleted by the person who
posted why it's like dude
everyone was having fun you know
everyone's having a laugh i hate that
just like why would you why would you
erase it yeah
it's weirdo where did weirdo
i think i'm found a reup yeah
let's see
man there's some straight up weirdos
weirdo on the phone okay so is this it
[Music]
yeah this is it now
why would you put why would you use a
horse for
someone with a back injury look at this
[Music]
this guy tried to think
what if that guy didn't have back injury
he sure does now that's
it's a this isn't real you think it's an
oh
yeah this is an act why'd you tell me
now
this is my first time seeing this one it
is i didn't add this one
well this guy tries to take down the
horse like the guy literally slides
under
like if it was fake look at him he tried
to tackle the horse
that didn't look fake to me
wait wait wait wait psych
okay like if it's fake i could be wrong
this is my
my my instinct tells me if it's fake how
could this guy try to drop kick the
horse
that seems like a risky play definitely
look at this
he slides under the horse's feet i think
it just
falls
whoa yeah
don't use a horse for for that purpose
holy [ __ ] let's see what the comments
say i don't care some
comments
[Laughter]
do you guys think it's fake what
someone's saying you guys reviewed this
before it's a demo i don't think so yeah
it's
yeah yeah who cares i've been doing the
show a long time it could be true and i
kind of thought
it seemed familiar when we watched it
too yeah it's a dummy for practice
people are saying yeah that's what i
thought
it's not a real person oh uh all right
forget it forget it or raise that from
your memory
is it
so i was trying to guess where this this
video took place
in georgia the country
somebody who wrote this says a country
at the intersection of europe and asia
thank you i know where georgia is
who wrote that
was it uab i honestly don't remember
yeah right
this is from like two weeks ago someone
whoever wrote this put a note they said
georgia a country at the intersection of
europe and asia
is a former soviet republic who what
have who wrote that
that's gonna have to check the history i
wasn't that wasn't
this took place in england and i an
island country in northern north of
europe
it's probably in there to clarify we're
not talking about georgia
well just say the country right
yeah who wrote it maybe i voted
i always i always fast i'm telling you
i'd look at the notes i don't know wanna
know what we're doing
for the show bro i wouldn't put that sub
note in there i always check mine does
the is way off
he does it sometimes could have been ian
it was he's often
wouldn't write that as one of these two
it was zachary
could someone have copy pasted maybe oh
it's definitely copy paste
come on it's easy to figure out
this is like i think it was a b i'm
going to find out right now because i'm
going into the document history
oh oh what wait what happened something
very special
to share with the audience right now oh
freddie
i'm ready in his sweater he came to say
hi i came to say hi to me
hello look at this guy he got a hair guy
yeah he got a haircut and he was so cold
outside we had to put a sweater on he
was shivering
yeah he's the best he loves this sweater
no
shredder has a sweater too but he's
sleeping yeah i don't want to disturb
shredder
all right who wrote the [ __ ] georgia
comment
are you getting man georgia i put all my
money all right
uh i'm voting okay go ahead i have bad
luck on these friday apps so go ahead
i'll take the back
friday the 13th dude ian are you voting
i voted yeah then thanks guys
i'm not going to vote i'm going to come
unless all over again i'm working on it
you know what i love ab so much we have
such a strong bromance
i'll take the blame for this year you
vote for yourself yeah but we're going
to see who did take the shot
you're going to take the shot for him
we're going to see who did it
yeah can we get mexican i'm craving
mexican and you keep okay
keep protecting me it's it's [ __ ] i
rejected it all week and i've been
eating italian all week for you
because we were feeling sick and i can't
do mexican diarrhea then i might as well
have something i enjoy
and make more dairy yeah did you have
diarrhea
yeah we did i think i had that fever
from indian food we had indian food on
that day
i literally had a fever like i think it
made us so sick
we thought we had coffee yeah well
because it was on the same day that our
housekeeper said her sister has covered
yeah and this
this food was so [ __ ] bad it gave me
a fever bro
gave me a 24 hour fever you ever had a
food that bad
and i've been my stomach hasn't been
okay the whole week it's good weight
loss though
[ __ ] it all out you know what time it is
dan how long does it take to look up the
note it's hard i i i don't have to get
back to you on
oh really you're you're not getting
there's like i mean it's the entire
document history of our after dark
documents and it was like
[ __ ] all right take your time get
find it out to the bottom of this yeah
i'm gonna do it right
so anyway this video took place in the
uh the
former soviet republic georgia which is
located between uh
kind of at the crossroads of europe and
asia yeah so
i thought it was at a trump rally it's
not but so the woman blows her nose into
a mask and then coughs on her hand
it's great we're [ __ ] doomed bro
we are doomed this lady gets it
we did all this conversation for this
video like it doesn't even matter where
it is
that's it no no we as a country as a
species are completely doomed
this is what's going on out there
between people talking about freedom
the master symbol of robert she's using
it like a tissue
and then she's coughing into her hand
but people are under her
oh some have a mask i see a lot have
masks face coverings not her though
not a lot yeah lady
you really don't get it dude
no we are doomed okay i experienced it
in first and i saw someone wearing a
mask and then it took it off the cough
and then put it back on oh yeah i've
seen that
because they want to keep the inside
nice and clean yeah but like hey i'm
here
i'm saying i um if i'm watching what
you're doing
then we're already too close for you to
be doing that yeah it's
it's obviously a goon move okay
vibe check just remember guys life is
fragile
life is fragile or whoa you can see it
coming from over here
just from that
so it's a wild ride right there life is
fragile alert
what would touch point say about this
clip okay pause
uh right here you can see the metal bar
come from the other side of the highway
the driver is thinking uh-oh
stop all right fast forward click play
let's see what happens next
oh bet you didn't see that one coming
stop thank you
there you go taj bueno
that's more like ridiculous taj
scooter getaway this is fantastic you
know i feel about scooters
this is this is good this is good
by the way thank you to everyone who's
been very active on the subreddit um
submitting videos
really strong stuff there lately right
now yeah
a lot of these come from the subreddit
oh watch this hila
straight up scooter
getaway
[Laughter]
they stopped chasing him they're like
you know
mobility mary back man you gotta you
gotta be impressed by the strength of
that scooter like
yeah took the doors out didn't even slow
him down
awesome it's awesome
actually what little don't you know is
that that was actually me over the
weekend
yeah i stepped out for an hour i stepped
out for an hour
that's me yeah it did take i was going
home to [ __ ] cause i wasn't gonna use
the mall bathroom
it's awesome they didn't even slow down
for the door what a g
it's all good uh wife exposed for
cheating
is there anything going on in this chord
what does that mean someone said you
guys should check out discord every once
in a while too
these guys are always on discord no yeah
it's just all positivity in there
okay what do they mean by that i don't
know they did a sad phase
oh you think just because me and eli
don't check in there enough you want us
to hear from us
yeah that's that's fair that's what they
mean i'm i can't i'm just not
i sometimes check in there but it's
usually at like 12 o'clock at night when
i'm done prepping and i
i um i'm in there at weird hours
yeah um okay would you do that
when i do this to ela so the story
is wait a minute what i might have an
update
okay dan's got an update who did it hold
on a minute
am i understanding this right i wish i
could show you this because i know
how you're going to react according to
this
your account ethan put that no oh my god
that's [ __ ] that's
that that didn't happen yeah what
account dan you know that's not
asian street productions your email
uh-oh no i didn't put that
i didn't put it
i'm just telling you what i'm what i'm
saying do you want a recount
wait what is this november 5th
at 901 pm there's an edit i asked
history productions i just i'm just
telling you what i'm finding
does the edit tell you what the editor
is it's color-coded
and it's listed pink wait
because someone one of you guys is
logged in because you use my account to
upload dan you're the one that has login
no i don't have a log into that account
that's your like main h3 account
but it's color coded i don't color code
red
no i don't even i don't even work on
this document i'm
i'm drilling in fake [ __ ] news there
you should you need to verify
you need to certify your results before
you come going public like that
i'm calling a breast meeting a total
landscape
season there's a lot of landscapes
trying to recover right now yeah i think
it's danica no i found the exact
uh entry where
it happened and there's a b ian
uh zach and h3h3 productions there's
four people that that
edited in this time you can't
tell us i'm going literally edit by edit
i know i just i found
i found the overall category we're
drilling in we're doing a recount right
now
okay wow we're gonna get to the bottom
of this but i'm just saying dan you
really
i'm just saying you're the evidence
doesn't lie nobody tampered with you
no but you're not freedom for the world
nah you gotta you gotta keep digging
that's some [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] he's stealing it
oh get out of here damn with that [ __ ]
you know it wasn't me you know goddamn
well i didn't add that
elo was immediately like no right elo
yeah
right thank you someone supports okay i
might
i might see what's going on here you
added an
edit that said where did this happen
okay thank you
so who added i said i want to know where
this happened and dan's like oh there's
a good question wait so you asked where
so somebody put in
right there okay no i no but i i know
where george that's not the point
i know that george is a country i asked
where did this happen
i know i said i want to know what's the
story here where did this happen so
okay but at least now we know why they
did that
yeah i know i i'm you're saying that it
doesn't seem bad in them
yeah really because you asked where was
yeah but why the whole georgia country
between europe and asia former soviet
question where is it could be i guess
interpreted in a couple ways
i didn't ask what is georgia
fine but you have some responsibility
here in this
you think so ethan sorry to say
in collusion is a fraud is a great uh
one of the greatest frauds in uh
internet history
interesting but do you don't you find it
funny that
you wanted to know where it happened as
in a while well i was like was this at a
trump rally was it at where was it
what's the context of this i want to
know where this happened
okay the jerk-off booth across from the
total landscape yeah so the answer was
was good they told you in georgia it
happened in georgia but
but like so and but they didn't give an
explanation of like
they just said they just copy pasted
what georgia is uh
don't you find that funny i mean it did
answer my question stop
i answered your question all right let's
move on dan you tell me when you get to
the bottom of it
okay so this woman cheated on her
husband and then at the baby shower
the husband comes with a lawyer and
video proof of cheating chaos ensues
here we go
a baby shower
[Music]
is
i like this new season of more
bro the lawyer brought a laptop with
video proof
how much a lawyer like that cost
oh my god where is that this is in
mexico
i think no no i mean like where did they
put a camera
to get this looks like he just had some
kind of ring thing in his house you know
why would you do it in a baby shower
he wanted the whole family to know i
don't i kind of doubt the validity of
this one to be honest
you think it's big oh my god well do you
have proof or is it just a tingle
it's a tingle well [ __ ] my you know well
let's keep watching i i
it's certainly suspect i would say
[Music]
i don't know it's pretty epic what
what oh he's the guy that you choose
he's there
whoa oh my god
oh
what do we think i mean it got off
pretty easy just a cake in the face
do you so what is what's the verdict on
this one fake or real
i don't want to think that it's fake
this video is so good if it's fake then
there'd have to be a reason for it to be
fake so where else has it
appeared you know what i mean i was just
pretty rural man
the footage is pretty crazy to have that
but well let's say he puts a camera in
the corner of his house
right outside the bathroom or wherever
they are the bedroom
you know and that guy fits that towel
nice he [ __ ]
fills that towel up
he really fills that dowel out he's got
back dates man
he reminds me of that that absolute unit
from
the super popular right now that big
like uh the pakistani guy oh he's
pakistani i wasn't sure yeah
yeah it's a unicorn look at that unit
does anyone have
any info in the chat well
presumably okay she's pregnant and i
think presumably it's not his son
yeah exactly so if that happened to me
you know or if that happened presumably
i think
he's pretty justified in his in his
anger and
to humiliate her he wants the whole
family to know right yeah
so you know generally i'm kind of
opposed to this kind of public
humiliation but i gotta say
if it's real god bless man you deserve a
show let's get you a maury
and that lawyer by the way he's there
for business bro that lawyer was there
for business he brought up the laptop
let's appreciate this lawyer
i love the briefcase i was just thinking
like
the other day i had this weird thought
that like is our briefcase is not
existing anymore like i remember when my
dad had a briefcase yeah yeah everyone
else who cares with briefcase
it's so heavy it's like a big heavy
thing i don't know
i would never use a bridge not a thing
anymore
i thought that was interesting well
people don't really use briefcases
anymore they use uh
bags they just have yeah like a laptop
because i think if you have a briefcase
and a laptop that gets to be pretty
heavy
some lawyers have them i mean they have
the laptop thing built inside
okay people are saying definitely not as
common
but if this video is fake then when the
fight be a little more intense
i mean that's an assumption you know
that's not really evidence but
let's watch it closely because i really
i i don't think it's fake and
it might be because i just like the
video too much and i
want it to be real sometimes videos are
too good
like this is a video that's maybe too
good like yeah the shot is amazing
the guy gets the cake in the face you
know what i mean it's just like well
let's
let's watch i'm choreographed
well the cameraman's clearly on it
look at this so business
you know
is
it'd be better if we spoke spanish
maybe they're just into some weird
cuckold fantasy
it's pretty big production
[Laughter]
i think it's real you do
so everyone's trashing that dude now
the cameraman doesn't know where to
point oh that looks fake
i'm calling fake look how he's like yo
settle down like this shot right here
there's a cut
watch there's a cut
oh right there there's a cut okay and
now he's going no no no no calm down and
then the cake comes in
that's very fake now there's a cut there
right here
fake i'm ruling fake after that cut
calling it ian is doing a vote
oh he's doing a vote i think it's a
straw poll down that cut
that cut sealed it for me why would
there could be a cut there
74 real so far why would there be a cut
right before the cake hits him in the
head i don't know it was totally not
videos too long
too long this is gold what did they cut
out one second
they cut out one second so why would
there be a cut there
did you find out who did it dan it was
you right because you're saying real
quiet no it's not me
was it it's i'm one of the only people
it couldn't have been uh
no i'm telling you ian hd productions a
b
zach those four people made an edit
right around 8
48 on november 5th one of those people
put it in there i i can't tell you which
one oh that's just really convenient
and thank you you're convincing a lot of
people now there's like
43 percent saying i mean why would there
be a cut and it's going up
it's only going up well if anyone i'm
making a persuasive argument if anyone
else wants to start
is going up there was one cut in the
video
50 fake yeah one cut in the video
right before the cake hits his face
there's no there's no valid reason for
that it's just a cut
you know damn well there's no such thing
as just a cut your honor
ladies and gentlemen of the jury there
is no such thing as justice okay
this is a prank bro
52 saying it's fake yeah i don't want to
be take i don't want to be
taken a fool you know what i mean i'll
be here
have some dignity
[Music]
the [ __ ] was that what was that
what do you mean what was that i don't
know what sound i just heard what was
that the video that you just played
well i'm an idiot i wasn't watching okay
imagine
imagine you're on an elevator first of
all my greatest fear is being torn in
half by an elevator i think all of us
have that fear
this lady she sees that the elevator's
going up and
oh
why she's like oh i should go she's
looking [ __ ] she
she's so close to being literally
chopped in half
she ate [ __ ] too cuz okay everything's
fake
no this one's real come on
she like jumped she was pretty high up
you could see her food at the floor and
[ __ ]
jesus she's gotta eat man
gotta eat you think she was just hungry
could be
oh i can only imagine the pain that this
guy
i'm gonna milk bang the [ __ ] out of you
later girl
i fight i don't know but
oh so this one so again okay this is
another one coming out of what appears
to be mexico
shot very similarly this one's
definitely fake
now why do you say definitely for
similar reasons to the
to the last one okay but you don't have
any proof yeah there's gonna be cuts
at very opportune times but like
the captures every every moment i find
it odd that it's coming out of the same
production company
really right like the same people yeah
it could be the same people
it's another cheating video i mean
they're good it looks more fake
looks like uh acting i mean they're
really good by the way
i think it's fake because he falls he
hurts his leg and then he starts limping
and then he's fine
he starts i just wonder what are they
getting at why are they doing all this
we're playing that on our show right
like what do they benefit from that
look at this this guy's pretty high up
this one's definitely fake but look he's
pretty high up
pretty pretty high up
you know so definitely fake
amy your your evidence is that he got
away
like he hurt himself right there right
yeah
oh i didn't finish it okay let's see oh
yeah this is hella fake
these are the same people i genuinely
think this is probably the same people
yeah we got a whole little uh production
company
we need to get these guys a show man
maybe it's like
a new form of like soap opera
content
dude i'm impressed this is just a phone
and a god's plan you know what i mean
traitor wants to come up take off him
come here freddy
shredder and a sweater
okay this one was wild y'all
imagine you're on the opera okay imagine
this let's set the stage for this video
you have got the call you need a heart
transplant to save your life
okay you know how that works you get on
a waiting list and you just pray
that somebody basically what happens is
somebody dies
who's on the organ donor list and they
take their heart and put it in your body
but it all happens so fast so
let's say you have heart disease and
they say you know
okay we're gonna put you on the list you
have to be ready to come to the hospital
with an
hour's notice so you get the call they
say
we've got a heart we need to operate you
need to get down here an hour
so he's in the operating table he's
ready to go
they're going to put a [ __ ] heart in
this guy because you got to get the
organ in there fast right this guy
died in a car crash who knows so they
fly in the heart
so they can get it in before it expires
so you're in the operating table you're
ready you're prepped you're ready to go
here comes the helicopter with your
heart to save your life
take a look at this crew's able to get
the heart out of that helicopter
it was then handed over to one of the
hospitals
now as that person leaves the helipad he
suddenly accidentally trips
on a metal plate to the ground dropping
the heart
others were quickly able to pick up that
organ and rush it inside for the
operation
the person who dropped it was apparently
not hurt
i'm not worried about him by the faa and
the
ntsb truly remarkable there andrew
incredible
you know when you drop something like
something wet on the floor but the heart
is like what is it there's no container
to it
well i think it was it was in a
helicopter crash they just brought it
out in a ralph's bag
like some snacks from the corner store
what but then they drop it on the damn
floor and i was covered in like grime
and [ __ ]
just straight up there what is it
holding like is it
well usually they they put it on ice
look at this crew's able to get the
heart
out of that helicopter they put it on
ice you know
it's in a literal plastic bag bro come
on please
how can i zoom i mean you're not going
to get more resolution but
here let's let's examine so here it is
i mean i would assume it's in some kind
of container and that's not just a
straight up heart in a bag
no it's going to be in like some sort of
thermos or like uh
yeah but but it was in a it was in a
helicopter crash so who knows what
happened i guess this room would have
fallen out
you know i mean that's kind of the size
of a heart isn't it like
this looks big medical
hey dude you're you're holding a human
heart bro can you watch your [ __ ]
step
you know what i mean was he is it so
much [ __ ] on the roof again i think it's
all debris from the crash
i think so much [ __ ] on the roof
dude he dropped that thing like a damn
dropping the heart he literally doesn't
even care about the heart he's like oh
my ankle
look at him he's like he doesn't even
look for the heart he's like oh my ankle
[ __ ]
guys there's a heart on the floor
there's a human heart on the floor
there's a hair on it i don't know
there's some moisture on where it hit
the floor
i'm saying is that that heart bounced
and rolled
dropping the heart there's moisture on a
metal plate
oh yeah oh yeah that thing rolled around
bruh look you can see it hit the floor
and roll there's no moisture there right
that look it flops around now there's
big-ass moist marks
so now they're gonna put that heart in
that poor guy with like grime and dust
on it and little stones and [ __ ]
would you still want that heart you're
like i'll wait for the next heart
so sir we had an incident upstairs
somebody dropped your heart and it
rolled on the ground for about five feet
would you like it
i'll take the next heart
this is your only opportunity okay give
me the heart
oh boy i'm [ __ ] out don't show this
video to the guy on the operating table
i mean it looks like you know you know
when you buy steak it's like on that
like that styrofoam and wax paper it
looks like that
falls to the ground dropping the heart
others work
fumble the heart he fumbled a
he was okay the guy who dropped the
heart was
fine unfortunately the the procedure was
a failure and the
guy died at the end thank you for
watching
great video huh what the [ __ ] take a
look at discord
what do we got open that image up okay
we found out who did it we know who did
it
i've got the video proof who was it fess
up now
i'll take the blame nope that was me it
was me and when did you know it was uav
i really did not know i really did not
know it was me why are you saying it
vicious
when ela asked she's like well you asked
the person and i'm like wait did he ask
me that
i'm oh what are we trying to get on a
technicality here
it's not a technicality you did it
well elon made a good point you did ask
yeah yeah that's too much
so so but like what's that how did you
know it's from georgia
you want to go down well it says
according to reddit so it's probably
just in the comments of the original so
but then how did you get where did you
copy paste this from
um i'm from flo the reddit that's all i
said i'm guessing
uh because i went back to the post right
now and i just seen a bunch of people
saying it's from georgia
no but where did you copy paste this
text from
i don't think he did man i think he was
trying to give you a little geography
lesson
oh oh you just wanted to make sure that
i knew where georgia was
i think so is that what happened i
strongly suspect that's what happened
no i'm sorry but wait wait this text is
different than what was there it says
it says that's home to caucus mountain
village and black sea beaches what the
[ __ ] does that mean
what the [ __ ] does that mean that's true
it is it's a longer version of it
that must just be like the google
results for uh
for the country of georgia fascinating
no
it's like my first mom i'm trying here
guys
no i'm not mad i'm just intrigued about
the origin i just want the origins
georgia yeah
okay it's it's the description if you
google georgia the country of georgia
it's like the google description of
georgia
i still love you ab you know that baby
well i'm not mad i'm not trying to make
this feel bad
i just want the origin story of how this
came to be so
i really don't recall i don't know who
in the chat is saying dan hates av i do
not hate bkb
get the [ __ ] out of here with that we
know we love baby
i can't yeah i can't tell you guys yeah
dan
i cannot tell you guys i'd probably have
a panic attack it wasn't for everyone
but
dan does so much for me i don't know
where they think people i love dan i
give our
we all give each other [ __ ] all the time
it's it's it's part of our dynamic don't
you guys think it's funny that
like we're trying to entertain you do
you guys think it's funny
yeah all right here before as we sign
off
we've probably been going for a while
right he's ready we've been going for a
really long time two and a half hours
yeah i felt like you know we were gone
all week i wanted to do a big old show
for you guys missed y'all yeah i gotta
be honest i missed you guys man i was
[ __ ]
i was like that was the longest we had
gone without making a show
in a minute i did not like it i did not
like it either
shred i like you you're so beautiful so
cute you're so beautiful such a good boy
i love my dog so much they're like my
heart i don't like it
god do you ever just think about how our
dogs are gonna die someday and just get
like super depressed
yeah jesus christ well because like
you know theodore's theoretically
supposed to outlive me so i don't ever
have to see him die
but like the tragedy of the of owning a
dog is that you fall in love with them
they're like
your best friends your heart and soul i
love my dog so much
and they're gonna [ __ ] die i mean i'm
gonna have to watch them die
and that's just it's so sad to me
and sometimes i just i mean it's fine i
usually can put the thought away pretty
fast but like sometimes i'll think and i
just get so sad i think imagine like
having to be with shredder as we put him
down
it's like the saddest [ __ ] thing it
just breaks my heart
i had to go through it over the summer
it was bad
it's just i wish dogs live forever you
know you want to get down
i wish shredder would live forever um
can we play that turkish fire
video i assume that's what oh sure
you're talking about someone paid a
hundred bucks
a hundred bucks to see well put it in
discord because in the meantime look at
who put in discord in the meantime
zach made some more parody songs for ian
potty all the time
[Music]
damn
[Music]
here just show ian uh just show ian dad
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
he has to go now
[Music]
all the time party all the time party
all the time
are you doing that zoom down my god does
he didn't even know that's happening
[Music]
i hope you're
[Music]
all the
[Music]
[Applause]
zach you have a beautiful voice thank
you
we missed you again oh he's back what
because he was gone
yeah he's gone peeing i'm assuming
[Music]
you know we don't we're not live anymore
so we have less enp
moments but rest assured it does still
happen the other day right before we
went live ian went to the bathroom so
it does still happen we love it almost
every time
almost every time
apparently i'm the only one with the
bladder here no you're not people
there's another one you guys want to
hear another one zach is that you on the
guitar and everything
yeah that's uh that's all me local dude
that's solo wow
[ __ ] sick brother
[Laughter]
just a regular guitar that's just an
acoustic guitar and i mic it put a
little chorus effect on there and
yeah this one's called run into the
bathroom
[Music]
[Applause]
run into the bathroom
oh wow dad look at those chops
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the show's almost over
has to go no matter what
shit's hard as [ __ ]
run into the bathroom
[Applause]
[Music]
on a road trip with hair
but also the late great eddie van halen
[Music]
run into the bathroom
we'll have to upload these uh
[Music]
we'll have to upload these to the uh
highlight together
like we did the last ones wow zach what
a talent
amazing thank you thank you
yeah the last one was fitting because i
mean we lost daddy van halen so i
wanted to do something in here right
right right right right
and memoriam memorial yeah also to ian
yeah ian do you have any well we're
pretty much done here but ian do you
want to say anything we're happy you're
back out of the
vortex it's really it's good to have you
back
i i hate to to even acknowledge this
at this point um but i really do have to
go
and it's not a meme no i know it's been
a long show
so thanks for sticking it out all right
well ian does have to go to the bathroom
so we better
just let him go but guys thank you
everyone for sticking around a lot of
fun i'm glad to be back
ian hey
this is a good sign off hey get that
water flowin
guys thank you everybody for watching we
better wrap it up because ian has to be
really bad
it's been a long time
[Music]
night
that's hot
[Music]
that was some dirty dubstep that was
some p step
that's hard man anyway we'll be back
next week same as always we got four
great episodes lined up for you guys
next week so
stick around you're listening to the hd
product
[Music]
take maybe get a
fever you ever get a fever from bad food
all right guys take care we'll see you
next time love you appreciate ya
might drink some mayo while the incest
honestly shredded will stop bopping my
freighters at the suite
we'll do the real raw ritual with more
and e.t
share my life with the ringer see y'all
love jimmy lee
they said we wouldn't come back but you
we always do embrace from the ashes like
the phoenix on the flex back to two
you